♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER
JUSTIN TRUDEAU GOT CAUGHT
WEARING BLACK FACE AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE PRETENDING TO
BE VERY, VERY SURPRISED.
BUT ARE YOU REALLY SURPRISED
IN FACT YOU PROBABLY COULD
HAVE GUESSED IT, ACTUALLY.
A LITTLE LIKE FINDING OUT
SUPER SENSITIVE
BROTHER-IN-LAW THE ONE WHO
TELLS YOU A FEMINIST THE ONE
ALWAYS SCOLDING YOU FOR YOUR
SEXISM IS, IN FACT, HITTING
ON THE BABYSITTER.
OF COURSE IS HE HITTING ON
THE BABYSITTER.
THE VIRTUE IS ALWAYS A COVER
FOR THE SIN.
THAT'S THE KEY TO
UNDERSTANDING THE MODERN
LEFT.
WHATEVER THEY ARE
ACCUSERSING YOU OF DOING,
THEY ARE DOING THEMSELVES
BUT MORE ENTHUSIASTICALLY.
AND THAT'S DEFINITELY THE
STORY OF JUSTIN TRUDEAU.
LIKE YOUR BROTHER-IN-LAW
WITH THE PONYTAIL TRUDEAU
BRAGS ABOUT BEING A
FEMINIST.
USE THE WRONG WORD IN HIS
PRESENCE AND HE WILL LAUNCH
INTO A SELF-RIGHTEOUS
LECTURE.
HE MAY BE THE MOST
SANCTIMONIOUS HEAD OF STATE
ON PLANET EARTH SO, OF
COURSE HE WAS LEADING A
SECRET LIFE AS A RACIST.
THAT'S WHY HE IS SO
SANCTIMONIOUS SO YOU WON'T
NOTICE.
TURNS OUT THERE ARE NOW AT
LEAST THREE SEPARATE
INSTANCES OF JUSTICE TRUDEAU
WEARING BLACK FACE AND AS HE
CONCEDED TODAY, THERE COULD
ABSOLUTELY BE MORE.
>> YOU LEFT US WITH THE
IMPRESSION THERE WAS ONLY
ONE OTHER INCIDENT AND SINCE
THEN GLOBAL NEWS HAS
RELEASED A VIDEO WHICH SEEMS
TO SHOW THERE WAS AT LEAST A
THIRD INCIDENT.
SO EXACTLY HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE YOU DARKENED YOUR SKIN
IN MAKEUP IN AN ACT THAT YOU
YOURSELF DESCRIBED AS
RACIST?
>> I SHARED THE MOMENTS THAT
I RECOLLECTED BUT I
RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS
SOMETHING ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE TO DO.
AND I APPRECIATE CALLING IT
MAKEUP BUT IT WAS BLACK
FACE.
>> Tucker: UNACCEPTABLE.
BUT HE DID IT AT LEAST THREE
TIMES.
MAYBE MORE.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU WORN
BLACK FACE?
PROBABLY RIGHT AROUND ZERO.
TRY NOT TO BE JUDGEY HERE OR
ANYTHING.
BUT EVEN ADJUSTING FOR
YOUTHFUL INDISCRETION, THREE
TIMES ON CAMERA.
THAT'S A LOT.
IT'S AN AWFUL LOT, ACTUALLY.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH JUSTIN
TRUDEAU?
IT TURNS OUT AND HE
EXPLAINED THIS TODAY THAT
JUSTIN TRUDEAU SUFFERS FROM
AN ESPECIALLY VIR LENT CASE
OF SOMETHING CALLED
PRIVILEGE.
>> I HAVE ALWAYS ACKNOWLEDGE
WOULD THAT I COME FROM A
PLACE OF PRIVILEGE, BUT I
NOW NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
COMES WITH A MASSIVE BLIND
SPOT.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
GOT THAT?
WHITE PRIVILEGE IS THE
PROBLEM HERE THAT'S
TRUDEAU'S EXPLANATION.
IF YOU ARE NOT LISTENING
CAREFULLY, IT MIGHT SOUND
LIKE JUSTIN TRUDEAU JUST
TOOK RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT
HE DID.
OH, BUT NO.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
HE TRANSFERRED IT.
WHEN TRUDEAU BLAMES
PRIVILEGE, IS HE MOVING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT HE
DID FROM HIMSELF TO THE REST
OF US.
IN OTHER WORDS, I DID
SOMETHING AWFUL BECAUSE
SOCIETY ITSELF IS ROTTEN,
THEREFORE, AND THIS IS THE
KEY, THEREFORE I NEED TO
KEEP TELLING YOU HOW TO LIVE
YOUR LIFE.
IT'S NOT A CONFESSION.
IT'S A JUSTIFICATION.
AND THE ONLY PEOPLE DUMB
ENOUGH TO BUY IT, ARE THE
NEWS MEDIA.
OF COURSE.
THE DUMBEST PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD.
OVER AT CNN, FOR EXAMPLE,
DON LEMON WAS DEEPLY
IMPRESSED.
>> WOW, A LEADER
APOLOGIZING, IT SEEMS ODD,
DOESN'T IT?
I MEAN, BECAUSE WE HAVE ONE
WHO DOESN'T BUT HE SAYS, YOU
KNOW, HE SAID HE DIDN'T
THINK IT WAS RACIST AT THE
TIME.
NOW HE KNOWS BETTER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I DO HAVE TO SAY THIS
BEFORE WE GO, THINK ABOUT IT
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO THINK
ABOUT IT, WHEN SOMEBODY
APOLOGIZES, WOW!
WE DON'T -- WE DON'T OFTEN
SEE THAT HERE.
ESPECIALLY A WORLD LEADER
WHO IS SAYING I SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN BETTER AND I'M SORRY.
YOU CAN FEEL ABOUT IT
HOWEVER YOU WANT.
THAT TO ME THAT DOES MEAN A
LOT.
I HAVE GOT TO GO.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IT MEANS A LOT TO
DON LEMON IT.
REALLY DOES.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A YEAR
MAKES.
REMEMBER ALL THE WAY BACK TO
WHEN MEGYN KELLY FOUND
HERSELF UNDER ATTACK IN
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME WAY,
THE DIFFERENCE WAS THAT
MEGYN KELLY NEVER WORE BLACK
FACE.
SHE WOULDN'T DO THAT SHE IS
NOT JUSTIN TRUDEAU.
SHE JUST MADE THE MISTAKES
OF NOT SEEMING QUITE
OFFENDED ENOUGH IN A TV
SEGMENT BY CERTAIN HALLOWEEN
COSTUMES.
FOR THAT CRIME DON LEMON
TOLD US SHE MUST BE
DESTROYED.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE HONEST.
MEGYN IS 47 YEARS OLD.
SHE IS OUR AGE.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A TIME
IN HER 47 YEARS THAT BLACK
FACE HAS BEEN ACCEPTABLE.
I WONDER HOW MUCH DIVERSITY
SHE HAS ON HER STAFF.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT THERE I WOULD
IMAGINE THERE IS NOT A LOT
BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
INFORMED HER.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE OF THE
LARGER CULTURE DON'T
UNDERSTAND ABOUT RACISM AND
ABOUT PRIVILEGE.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
KEEP IN MIND AND THIS IS
UNIVERSALLY TRUE.
IT WAS TRUE OF JIMMY SWIGERT
AND TRUE OF JUSTIN
AND TRUE OF TUSTIN
AND TRUE OF TRUTIN
AND TRUE OF TRUDEN
AND TRUE OF TRUDEAU AND
PROBABLY DON LEMON.
THE MORE SANG
NO MATTER WHAT HE DOES?
I THINK YOU KNOW THE ANSWER
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, HAVE YOU
SEEN IT BEFORE EARLIER THIS
YEAR THE GOVERNOR RALPH
NORTHAM CAUGHT WEARING BLACK
FACE.
CLANHOOD.
HE STILL WON'T TELL US WHAT
IT WAS.
HE WAS WEARING BLACK FACE OR
A CLAN HOOD NORTHHAM THE
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT SAID HE
DIDN'T NEED TO RESIGN OVER
IT.
THE LEFT PRETENDED TO CARE
FOR A MY MINUTES, WE ARE SO
UPSET AND FORGET THE WHOLE
THING HAPPENED.
NORTHAM SAID THE WHOLE
INCIDENT SHOWED DEEP WOUNDS
IN VIRGINIA.
WHAT HE DID SHOWED DEEP
WOUNDS IN THE WHOLE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA.
IN OTHER WORDS, NORTHAM
HIMSELF WASN'T GUILTY OF
ANYTHING, BLACK FACE OR A
CLAN HOOD, IT WAS THE PEOPLE
OF VIRGINIA WHO WERE
RESPONSIBLE.
THEY HAD THE COLLECTIVE
GUILT.
AND THAT GUILT COULD ONLY BE
BY GIVING RALPH NORTHAM MORE
POWER.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT IS
ALWAYS ABOUT.
ALWAYS.
IT'S ABOUT POWER.
WHEN YOU MAKE A MISTAKE, IT
MEANS YOU ARE A SINNER, AND
YOU MUST BE DAMNED.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH DIVERSITY IN YOUR
OFFICE SAYS DON LEMON.
WHEN THEY SCREW UP.
IT'S SOCIETY'S FAULT.
MEANING IT'S YOUR FAULT.
SO THEY HAVE GOT YOU COMING
AND GOING.